to present the awards for screenwriting
here's an actor from Australia who
starred in road warrior and the year of
living dangerously and in 1981 s best
actress for Coal Miner's Daughter Mel
Gibson and [ __ ] Spacek
for Best Screenplay written directly for
the screen the brilliant and most
deserving nominees are Lawrence Kasdan
and Barbara Benedict for the Big Chill
Ingmar Bergman
Afeni and Alexander and Alice Arlen for
Silkwood
horton Foote attendant
laughter and Walter F Parkes for war
games and the winner is the winner is
Horton
I'm overcome and I'm very grateful to
the Academy I'd like to express my
gratitude to the cast and crew of tender
mercies and particularly to my old and
dear friend Robert Duvall for his
marvelous work which was the heart and
soul of our film to Australia for my new
friend the very gifted director Bruce
Beresford forum that produces to their
loyalty and courage Marianne and Phillip
Hoebel to John cone and Barry spikings
for all of their tender administration's
to my agent and friend Lucy Kroll - my
wife and children for their kindness
their devotion and their steadfastness
in good times and bad thank you all
of five nominees for Best Screenplay
based on material from another medium
three will based upon stage placing two
upon novels and those nominees are
Harold Pinter for betrayal Willy Russell
for educating Rita James L Brooks
winner is James L Brooks potential in
dinner
thank you very much I want to thank
Larry McMurtry for wonderful book
Jennifer Jones Simon for all her help
Jeff Berg was a comfortable office and
left it to work like a process server to
try and get this picture made
I want to thank paramount first and last
the only ones who would make the movie
and the cast had so much to do with the
script finally it was all redefined
finally it was an actor's picture I'd
really like to share it with them and
thank you very much oh I'm sorry I just
want to forgive me I just want to thank
three women I want to thank my sister
Diane I want to thank my daughter Amy
and I want to thank my wife Holly thank
you